hello internet so i'm super grateful to
be here today
on free code cam to talk to you about
the winners of the js 13k
games that's right so in other words 20
winning games
that means 20 amazing code snippets from
20
insanely talented developers my name is
anyakuba and i'm a software developer
and a youtuber who loves to create
all sorts of awesome tutorials online
but hey today's not about me
it's about these guys if you are just
starting out in javascript or perhaps
you're well seasoned but haven't
actually heard of the js 13k games
before well you are in
for a treat as a judge on the 2020 js 13
games panel
i had first time experience of these
amazing developers so i really can't
wait to show you that code today
it is absolutely incredible to see what
these guys have built using just
javascript
no libraries that fits in a 13kb file
but first what is js 13k games you ask
as the name would suggest all your game
and game asset
should be smaller than or equal to 13
kilobytes that is exactly
13 312 bytes to be precise
you can of course zip it but don't over
complicate building the zip package it
should open
on any platform anywhere anytime and you
can
use tools that minify your javascript
source code if that helps too
two you are not allowed to use any
external services or libraries
you can't use libraries images or data
files hosted on
server or services that provide any type
of data
for example google fonts are not allowed
which let's face it and while the
developers are so often scrolling
through
npm to find the latest package that will
do some sort of shortcut
it's nice to strip back a little bit
right and just use plain old
vanilla javascript number three stick to
the theme
this year's theme was 404 so the number
404
so if you know what that means you know
like get creative with it
the theme is announced every year in
august so it was announced this
august and that is what the developers
had to work
with and finally how many games can you
submit well you can submit as many
as you want you can also work on a team
you work with your dog like it doesn't
matter just get involved it's really
meant to be
a lot of fun this awesome competition
was started in
2012 by anjay mazur he created it from
scratch
out of his own pocket sending out you
know like t-shirts and gifts
using the money that he had saved up
what an awesome guy
i can't wait to introduce him to you and
now hello there
my name is andre mazur i'm the creator
of the js 13k
games competition and i have to admit
that
i'm impressed with quality of the games
submitted this year
it's so cool to see that the games are
getting better and
better every single year since 2012.
i'm also proud of the community because
even though it's a competition
developers are helping each other to
build
better games to fix issues and the bugs
if you're interested about how those
games were built
remember that all the games from all the
years
the source code is on github so you can
learn from that
um okay um thanks anya for doing the
video and helping promote the
competition
i really appreciate this thank you bye
okay
thank you andre and thank you also to
free code count for giving us your
platform to showcase
this year's winners give it up for bo
from free code camp
hi i'm beau from freco camp js 13k
games is a great initiative we're all
about learning to code at freecoatcamp
and coding a game is a great way to hone
your skills
i think 13 kilobytes is a brilliant
constraint
constraints often lead to greater
creativity
and that's definitely true with this
year's winners we're honored
to showcase these projects on our
channel i encourage everyone watching to
try to create your own 13k
game yourselves and see how it improves
your skills
okay so hopefully you're ready to start
looking at some code because
next up we have the 20 overall winners
starting from descending order so number
one don't forget i will be putting a
link to all the developers where you can
find them on twitter
as well as play their games and also of
course their github source code for each
game too
let's do it
hello everyone my name is remy vancillin
and i'm a french game development
hobbyist i've been participating in j7k
games
every year since 2013 and this year
i made ninja versus evil corp
every year i try to make something a bit
unique for js13k
and try to push the limits of what you
can get within the size constraint
instead in 2020 i only had a week to
work on my game
so i decided to go for something a bit
less risky
and i wanted to polish it as much as
possible
one of my favorite game genres is 2d
platformers so i decided to build just
that
with two main goals in mind first
make it snappy i wanted it to be fast
and i wanted the controls to feel right
second
have preset levels typically i make
games
where you have randomly generated levels
the benefit of that approach is that it
takes
less bites and also less creativity
you only need to have a decent algorithm
this year i wanted to make a game that
lasted about 5 minutes
with a beginning an end and
well-designed level
some other goals came after such as
having levels represented by floors
in the tower similar to the die hard
game
if you've ever played that i wanted to
have
shortcuts optimized for speed running
and polish the game as much as possible
i was on vacation in quebec when the
theme was announced
so i had some time to prepare i was able
to sketch the character
his trademark floating bandana some
basic levels
enemies and various elements i was also
able to write a few algorithms
on my notebook
like i mentioned before one of my main
goals was to have preset levels
it's not something i usually do and i'm
pretty happy with the result
so i can say that one of the main things
i'm proud of is the level design
a lot of it is due to how much time i
spent adjusting the levels
thanks to all the people who play tested
the game and the part i'd like to focus
on is how i managed to squeeze 17 levels
in a 13 kilobyte game
more specifically how the ai was defined
if you look at levels.js you'll notice
that all the level matrices are stored
as json
and the enemy behavior is defined next
to each matrix
the game is filled with cameras that
typically transition between two angles
and guards that transition between two
positions
one of the constraints was that i needed
all their cycles to be consistent
i couldn't have them be framer dependent
or you have the slightest difference
between two runs
otherwise speed running would just suck
in other words
i needed to be able to determine their
exact state based on the current clock
if you look at the way those cycles are
defined it is actually relatively
readable
i didn't want to use some obscure arrays
as it'd be much harder to read and
maintain
everything follows a builder pattern
that allows for a lot of control
while still taking very few buys
for instance cameras are defined by
their position
and initial angle in the constructor
and then their behavior can be chained
if the camera needs to rotate by a
certain amount
we can simply call rotate by and provide
the angle
and the time it should take to perform
that rotation
if it needs to wait we can call wait and
provide the duration
and if we need two cameras to have the
exact same cycle
but with a slight offset we can call
with phase
and guards also follow a very similar
pattern
the details of how it all works under
the hood iron cycle.js
it's all very simple algorithms and this
is why i'm still proud of it
it lasts for a lot of control without
looking too complex
which is what most code should be we
should always try to make it as readable
as possible
anyway i hope you like this quick
walkthrough of a small portion of my
code
if you're interested in seeing progress
on various unfinished game projects
you can follow me on twitter at remvst
and i hope to see you all joining js13k
next year
hello i'm tom hammels i'm a dutch
developer who also makes a video game
sometimes
and for this year's year's turning k jam
i made
edge not violent it's a puzzle game on
an
infinitely repeating world
i really like a towel based box pushing
games like chocobon
and i've already made several of them
this is probably my most complex one yet
i've been sitting on the idea for this
game for a while
and the gem was a good opportunity to
develop it and design some cool puzzles
for it
so let's talk about the rendering for a
bit
each frame in the game is drawn using
three steps in the first step
i create multiple gaps that serve as
sprites for the various puzzle elements
like walls and boxes
these are drawn using the rough library
which generates
nice hand-drawn looking shapes
the second step runs the current puzzle
state using these sprites
like this then finally it will draw the
level repeatedly
to fill up the entire game canvas and i
really like the bit of code that handles
this so today i'll explain how this
infinitely wrapping world works exactly
so for demonstration purposes i've
regenerated the level image from the
game instead of generating one from
scratch just to keep it simple
now then i've isolated code in this
sample i'll go over the most important
bits but if you want to toy around with
helping you can access the example with
this link
so let's go through it the core of the
dialing
magic happens here with the x and y
offsets
these essentially affect how the levels
are tiled
for example if you play the game then
you know that this level can't be solved
because the crate can't reach the goal
but if we change the y offset to 2
the level becomes a straight line and
the puzzle becomes solvable
it's kind of complicated but it is used
in a lot of
tricky puzzles so
next we calculate how much left scan
fit on the screen exactly the clip
offset here
here adds a small margin to the level
border
but it also shows if you put this
into as a negative value then you can
confirm that scope
actually works because then levels that
are very near the border
won't get drawn either so this
essentially makes sure that nothing will
be drawn if it will
end up being nearly or completely
visible
invisible anyway so
finally a nested for loop
actually draws levels note that levels
further away from the center will get
more transparent so if i zoom out
all the way then you can see that the
wrapping will go
on for a bit but eventually it'll become
so opaque that
it will stop drawing
so when drawing the image with an offset
defined we shift the image out on the
grid
which you can kind of see here because
of the shape
so if i enable the coordinates display
you can see that the image also shifts
two steps down for each step on the
y-axis kind of like a staircase
and that's due to the level offset
why i said earlier and
that's pretty much it once again you can
view the code snippets here
uh do consider playing edge not found
first if you haven't so you can learn
how this level wrapping is used for the
more tricky puzzles
so i hope this inspired you to make your
own infinite worlds
if you like this then you can find me as
a rory excellence victor uh for more of
my things
and if you look the name up on github
then you should be able to find the full
source code of the game
bye and thanks for watching
hey i'm caustic1337 we with my friend
lamp sprites created the game called
church before gem started i decided that
i want to create game where everything
is rendered in a single screen fragment
shader
this technique is not often used in game
dev but it's very common in demo scene
and on websites like shader toy
i never created any games like this so
it was an experiment for me
in a nutshell shader is a program
executed on a gpu
you can think of a single screen
fragment shader as a function that
returns pixel color
based on its position since this
function runs on gpu it's pretty fast
and you can do fancy things there
this has some pros and cons comparing to
usual techniques
like drawing sprites with textures so
the goal for me was to make the most of
pros and try to make cons negligible
one of the pros is that you can get this
new laser effect essentially for free
first off all geometry is represented
with sign distance fields or
sdfs in short sdf is a function that for
any point in space returns distance to
the closest geometry
and it's positive if you are outside of
geometry and negative otherwise
in our game we actually have three sdfs
for bounds checkpoints and
deadly zones there are a lot of awesome
articles in internet about how to
construct sdfs go read them if you are
interested
after you created your sdf you can for
example render pixels white whereas df
is negative
and the black where it's positive so you
can see your geometry
after that creating neon effect is very
simple it's this simple equation
parameter g corresponds to brightness
and p for blurriness
it's very simple effect but it looks
pretty after that
to make it look 3d ish just render the
sim multiple times
each time slightly offsetting can
scaling the layer
that's basically everything about
rendering almost all objects in game are
rendered this way
including the spider protagonist
collision checks and game are done in
shader as well
to check collision you only need to
evaluate your sdf and spider position
and if it's less than spider size like
if distance to closest geometry is less
than your size
then you are collecting something after
that you can calculate
surface normal vector by calculating
gradient of sdf in needed point
to pass this data from shader to js code
i write
this data in first three pixels of the
screen
they are bottom left although they are
very small to spot them
there are ways to do this better but it
takes a little of code and works ok
let's talk about music a bit i'm not
good at composing music so i try to make
it as generative as possible
all sounds and music and game are done
using plain web audio ip
web audio ip is kinda cool it's like a
modular synthesizer
where you create audio processors and
route them in any way you want
so this piece of code generates ambient
music in game
basically it creates three sine wave
oscillators each of them slightly
detuned with another low frequency
oscillator
then they all are summed up and passed
through echo
with huge amount of feedback and reverb
to create nice ambience
every time you place checkpoint chord
changes i have hardcoded a bunch of
random chords in a minor scale
they are just changing in loop also
every 3 seconds according versions
changes randomly chord inversion is when
chord nodes
are shifted octave up and down the chord
stays the same but
it sounds differently with huge echo it
creates interesting effects sometimes
all other sound effects are created with
web audio ip as well
they include ring modulation essentially
it's just
signal multiplication and some filters
all these effects except reverb are
available out of the box with web audio
ip
the last thing i'd like to tell you
about is this little piece of code
this is definitely not the code you
would like to see in production it's
very high key but for fitting a game
in 13 kilobytes it did its work pretty
well
it is used in intro and autocad scenes
where text is printed on screen
basically it prints text to converse
character by character
it also can evaluate code to modify some
internal state
for example for moving to a new line
changing delay between prints
printing whole string at once and other
things this function utilizes async
await.js
without it this code probably could be a
lot larger
here is example how it is used
strings with exclamation point prefixes
are evaluated
anyways i hope you learned something
here if you want to learn more
check out whole code of our game on
github you might find
more hacky tricks there if you want to
learn shaders
check out book of shaders it's an
awesome introduction to shaders
also check out shadertoy.com it's a huge
community of people writing shaders
you can learn a lot there you can follow
me on github as caustics1337
and on twitter as caustics 13 337
and i will be glad to see you all at
next year's
js13k
for this recording i will be reading it
on behalf of maxine
hi i'm maxime web dev passionate of code
golfing
puzzle games and css for js 13k 2020
i wanted to make a 3d game using css 3d
and emoji my game is about helping a
train
to cross bridges using optical illusions
it was inspired by the indie game fez
and the mobile games monument valley
earlier this year i made a micro
framework cs3d
framework allowing to render a plane
a sprite or a cube with a single line of
code
these 3d shapes are simply made of html
elements
and so they can contain anything you
want css gradients
images texts emojis so this gave me the
idea to create 3d emoji
i put one emoji on the front one emoji
on the back
and i filled the exterior with colored
planes like an ice cream sandwich
for example this train is made up of 16
planes after adding some
tree sprites around the train and a few
planes under it for the track
the illusion of movement is made with
simple css animations
that make the track and the trees scroll
infinitely from right to left
even though the rest of the scene is
completely fixed
here is the css code used for this
and that's how i made my title screen
next i'm going to show you how to
implement the
optical illusions in my games puzzle
for example in the third level of the
game
the player must switch between 2d view
scene from the side and 3d view with
perspective
to help the train move from track piece
to another
first the switch between 2d and 3d is
made by transitioning the css 3d
perspective value
if it's low the perspective will be
enabled
if it is high the scene will be in 2d
you may notice that this kind of puzzle
violates the laws of physics the train
is simultaneously at different places of
the scene depending on which button is
pressed
2d or 3d and how much it has progressed
through the bridge it took me a few days
to figure out how to implement this
i declared three views of the same scene
a real one saying where the track parts
are located in the real world
two virtual ones saying where the track
parts appear to be
in 2d and in 3d
in the real world no block parts are
aligned in the
3d virtual view the blocks 1 2 and 3
and the blocks 5 6 and 7 are aligned
thanks to an optical illusion
as well as here in the 2d virtual view
the blocks 3
4 and 5 are aligned thanks to an optical
illusion
finally here's what happens when a
camera transition occurs
the train moves on the part 2 in 3d view
this part has a virtual 3d position so
the train uses this position
as if it were real but in reality it
flies in the air
to preserve the optical illusion
the player clicks on the 2d button at
this moment the train is instantly
teleported and scaled up into
its real position so you don't see it
fly in the air
and then the camera transitions as if
the train had always been there
if we are on a part that also has a
virtual position in 2d view
which is the case for the fourth part of
the puzzle
then the trainers teleported a second
time just after the camera has finished
moving
once again it will fly in the air to
preserve the illusion
the same thing happens when
transitioning from 2d to 3d
thanks for watching this video as always
there will be more information about
this game
and the making of it in the description
below
hey i'm ian xiao from taiwan i am a
software engineer
currently based in seattle i am the
creator of the stolen sword
stolen sword is a action platform game
that you can play with only one finger
and
basically you play a swordsman trying to
reclaim this word from a thief and
the sword was used to suppress demons so
now that it's being stolen
the demon have been released so you have
to
fight him along the way
and visually this game was inspired by
a 2002 movie called
hero
i was obsessed with the late 56 in the
movie so
i just want to kind of recreate it the
scene
in the game and also crouching tiger
hidden dragon is another movie that i
referenced
so today i'm gonna share a little bit of
how i create
water effects in the lake level
the water effect can be break into three
parts
repo and reflection
and the gradient mask the repo
is just two semi lips the lower part has
a outer shadow and the upper part has an
inner shadow
so it creates a 3d illusion just like a
crater the code snippet here
is not an actual code it's just a high
level concept of the implementation
because the actual code is way uglier
first i use the scale function to squash
the circle a little bit
to make it more like a oval instead of a
circle
so so that it looks like
it's on the water surface then i use
radial gradient to draw the shadow
i use color stops to control the shadow
goes inward or outward
and then use ellipse function to
draw a half of circle
most of the image assets in this game
are vector
graphics it's basically
layers of shape defined by a path
which is an array of points
so to draw this image
i simply traverse the path array and
connect all the points together
with line two function that's it
based on that the reflection is pretty
straightforward
first add some transparency by tweaking
the global alpha
and then add a little bit of vibration
by
adding random number to the x-axis
coordinate
so that it looks like it's on the water
surface
and lastly flip the shape across the
y-axis
but the reflection of the enemy is
another story
enemies are simply chinese characters
drawn with
failed text function i didn't find a way
to flip the text
i do know there is a transform function
but i just didn't figure out how to use
it
so i take advantage from chinese
characters
every enemies appears in the leg level
are vertically
symmetrical which means the characters
looks identical even when it's upside
down
and if it's not symmetrical then it must
be a character that you can find a
upside down version of it the last
element of the
water effects is the gradient mask
it is used to show that the player is
dipping the water
and it's basically it's just
drawing the player again but this time
it is filled with linear gradient
because the gradient is using absolute
coordinate
its position is fixed no matter where
the shape is
so i can easily keep the boundary at the
same high as the
water surface so that's a high level
overview of how i created water effects
in my
13k entry and i really appreciate jfk
for
hosting this amazing event i've learned
a lot from the community
so i highly recommend you to give this a
try next year
and you can find me on github and
twitter
my username is ciaogu that's
csiaogu and
feel free to reach out thank you
reading on behalf of michael farren
my name is michael faran i am a software
engineer for minneapolis minnesota usa
i spent most of my time professionally
building web applications in reacts and
typescript
occasionally i like to build javascript
games in my free time
this is my fourth time participating in
the js 13k
i wanted to take a different approach to
the 404 theme
than the common not found approach to
help my game stand out
one of the ideas i brainstormed was to
use 404 as a time period for the setting
of my game
from there the idea to use ancient
greece led to what became the last
spartan i like to play hack and slash
games as it felt like a good
genre that could be achievable within
the constraints of that nkb
this is my animation class that powers
all the animations for the player and
enemies in the last spartan this class
accepts keyframe animation
configurations as
input and interpolates values between
those keyframes to create
smooth animation loops for idling
attacking
jumping etc in my game what i really
like about the solution
is it allows me to make some really
impressive animations utilizing each
component of my characters individually
the head the shield the sword and each
leg and by only defining a subset of
positions and rotations for each
when rendering each of these parts of
the character i use the offsets that
were generated by the animation class
between the keyframes
and i get smooth animations without
defining every
single frame myself thanks so much for
watching
please do reach out to me on twitter or
check out my project
in the description below where you can
play it and check out the code
for this game i will be reading on
behalf of saud
when asked about his favorite code
snippet for the game
he chose this one right here a little
brief note about it
is when creating the level editor for
the game
i didn't want to impose any sort of
constraint on players
so i wanted the space to feel like an
infinite grid
i thought a lot about how to maintain
the state of a virtually infinite grid
with different type of platforms
and obviously an array wouldn't suffice
since that would mean the grid has a
start index
and no platforms can be created before
the start index
finally i came up with this snippet what
it does
is keep track of the negative offset or
in other words the number of platforms
beyond the start index
represented by negative x y a player has
traveled
and then shift the whole level data
so a 2d array by that amount
the grid can now be virtually infinite
in all directions
and not limited by the start index of
the arrays
you can find more about this game in the
description below
for this game i'm going to be reading on
behalf of mark vasilkov
my name is mark vasilkov and i'm a
russian israeli computer programmer and
security enthusiast
i love video games the thing i do for a
living are distinctively not
video games though life's unfair like
that
a proper puzzle game can be designed as
follows
players are taught a game mechanic this
allows them to
solve puzzles of progressing difficulty
then another mechanic is introduced
upping the combinatorial complexity
and then we repeat until done this game
or in other words i want to google that
game is an opposite of that
a whimsical experience with no
meaningful level progression
each level changes the rules there is
nothing to learn
no understanding to develop this design
was suggested by my beautiful wife
natalia as a satisfactory metaphor
for the entirety of the year 2020 in
regards to the code snippet i am most
proud of
i'm ashamed of most of it really but i
think the following main loop
turned out nicely making a smooth
animation in javascript is surprisingly
difficult
modern screens don't have any semblance
of consensus as to how many frames per
second to render
a 4k screen connected to my mpb runs at
omega 30 frames per second
because of apple gaming laptops on the
other hand
commonly run at around 300 frames per
second
this obviates the need to decouple
movements computations from the refresh
rate
we cannot do plus plus x in every frame
as the results would be very different
between machines and even on the same
machine depending on
rendering complexity gc pauses and so on
the simple solution is to use delta t
the time interval between frames
as a multiplier for movement distance
this approach has issues of its own
though
for one we are dealing with floating
point numbers that are close together
some computations tend to accrue large
errors
look up catastrophic cancellation as i
can't pretend to explain it
then again there are state changes that
are abrupt
these can be difficult to express in
terms of delta t
also jumps as in 2d platformer will miss
their
apex point when the frames per second is
slow
the solution i arrived at which can
absolutely be
improved on is the fixed step loop
showing in the
listing the only requirement is your
render function
should be capable of learning objects
between their current and last known
positions
meaning that every object stores its
previous coordinates
conveniently when you're writing a valid
integration this is already the case the
update function then uses the fixed step
of 0.02 seconds
or 50 updates per second in this example
it can do plus plus x for all its worth
and the animation will still be smooth
and independent of the
rendering frames per second moreover the
update function doesn't run
in every frame reducing the cpu load
at the expense of game's responsiveness
to controls yep
there's also a safeguard for when an
update takes an inordinate amount of
time
although the end result will still look
janky
implementing an algorithm that would
scale the tick crate based on the
observed performance of the machine
is left as an exercise for the reader
once again you can find more on mark's
game
in the description below including
weatherfan on github
his homepage and his twitter handle
hi everyone my name is jerome leconte
and i'm a software developer
specialized in javascript one month per
year i'm also a game developer for the
js 13k games competition
in 2020 the theme was 404
and it turns out that my home province
of ontario canada has numbered its
highways in the 400 range
so there is a real highway 404 and i
decided to make a game about it
the goal is to survive the perils of the
highway which are triggered by http
status code
404 makes the road behind you disappear
501 makes the lane ahead unavailable and
so on
today i'm going to share with you how
linear interpolation
also commonly referred to as lerp in
game development
allowed me to add some juice to my game
lerp is a function that takes a value in
a range 0 to 1
and maps it to another value in the
range between a min and a max
using a linear scale for example
if the min is 10 and a max is 20
at t equals zero the function will
return 10.
at t equals 0.5 it will return 15.
at t equal 1 it will return 20.
this is the function that my game loop
calls on every frame to calculate the
distance
that a car is moving forward it uses the
elapsed time
usually tens of milliseconds and
multiply it to the car speed
that i've expressed in pixels per second
to get a distance
which i then add to the car's y position
another way to think about it is that
there's an acceleration factor
always set to 1 that gives me the full
car speed
on every single call where this is a
problem
is that on the title screen the game
loop is not running
and as soon as the game starts the car
is going to move
from zero to full speed in an instant
similarly when a car crashes the game
loop exits
and the car comes to a full stop
instantaneously
and this is where lerp is going to come
in andy
now when the race just started i can
progressively increase the acceleration
factor from
0 to 1 in about a second
and a half using the log lerp function
this is going to feel like the car is
progressively accelerating to its full
speed
similarly when a car crashes i can now
decrease the acceleration factor from
one to zero
in about one and a half second giving
the impression that a car is slowing
down to a full stop
i was so happy with the result that i
started using lerp everywhere
another instance is in the function that
steers the car from
left to right the idea is the same
elapsed time
times car speed gives you a distance and
the distance either
negative or positive depending which of
the left or right arrow key was pressed
last
once again the problem as the car moves
from zero
to full speed on the left through on the
right as soon as the
key is pressed which makes for precise
control
a bit difficult using lerp
i can also increase the direction factor
from zero to minus one
or zero to one in about a quarter of a
second
and this gives the car some inertia
which makes for a nicer driving
experience
and that's about it you can play highway
404
by visiting bitly forward slash hwy-404
the source code is on my github account
and i've written
about the making of in a medium article
you can also visit my website
herebyfrogs.com
or follow me on twitter hatre frogs
thank you for listening
hi my name is cody and i am the creator
of mini punk
a 3d action adventure game for the 2020
js 13k
games competition let's take a quick
look at the game
the enemy of the game is the evil 404
megacorp
they are threatening to take over the
internet and you must stop them
it's a third person 3d game with
melee combat
gives you an idea of the gameplay of the
game
now i'd like to talk to you about some
of the technical details of the project
it's part of the competition the game is
open source and available on github
i wrote a postmortem that talks about
the origin of project
some of the technical details in terms
of choosing the project
it's based on some of the ongoing
debates about internet censorship
it's really because i'm excited about
the upcoming release of cyberpunk 2077
the game itself uses a voxel engine
similar to minecraft
unlike minecraft where each tile is one
meter by one meter by one meter
the voxels in mini punk are one meter
tall and four meters wide and four
meters deep
this helps with performance um and keeps
the code a little bit smaller
one of the most interesting technical
details of the game is the bloom effect
which creates this neon glow the
implementation is based on an opengl
tutorial that i ported to webgl
which creates this great city glow
effect
here's the code for the bloom shader
as you can see most of it is implemented
in glsl
that's the language that your video card
uses to actually render
and it's done as a post-processing
effect
there you have it that's a quick look at
mini punk
for the js 13k games competition
thank you
hello i'm nicholas and i created a game
for js13k
called searching 404.
it's a classic single-player dungeon
crawler game
containing one level with smaller
labyrinths
puzzles
two different weapons with weapon
progression
two different enemies to fight
and finally a boss fight
this also features a static lighting
system
[Music]
projectiles particles
[Music]
and some very basic audio effects
[Music]
in all this i managed to cram into a
zipped package at
13 kilobytes
so does this mean that i'm working as a
full-time game developer
no it doesn't i'm actually working as a
system administrator
maintaining servers and networks 8 hours
a day
but in the evenings and weekends i'm
creating games
this was the first game i created in
javascript
usually i'm creating games in java or
c-sharp
in unity mostly for the ludum dare
gaming competition
but i wanted to do something new and
decided to participate
in jay's 13k this year
i never thought i would be able to
finish a game nor create a 3d game in
just
13 kilobytes but with a few weeks works
two three hours a day i managed to
create this game and i was
very surprised when i saw that i ended
up at place 11
and at place 5 in the gameplay category
[Music]
the source code you can easily tell by
the source that i'm actually a java
developer
and doing my first game in javascript
[Music]
i was using es6 which gives me
classes and the possibility to use
class inheritance instances and
static class variables
[Music]
is there any code that i'm proud of as
this is the first time i'm doing a game
in javascript and especially since i
managed to do
a 3d game in just 13 kilobytes i'm proud
of all the code
but i've have the big one that i'm extra
proud of it will probably be the code
that adds
static lights to the level because
without the lights
the game would be well the ambience
the light gives it would miss a lot of
that
the algorithm for adding the lights is
very silly
simple and not efficient at all but
javascript executes it's very fast so
for my level that is 64 by 64 tiles
just does that code in just a few
[Music]
milliseconds
[Music]
so how does this light code work well
the entire level is built of
grids like this where every grid is
tiled so it can either be a floor like
this
then we can add walls like this
and finally a light source in the middle
here
so the light code will loop through all
of these
tiles looking for a light source the
first time
and it will set the light value to 1
like this
then when a loop enters again every tile
will check
enable tiles so when it enters this one
it will find that the bottom
tile has a brighter light value
than it currently has which means it
will
set the light color like this then we'll
continue do that for the rest of the
tiles
now when the loop enters again
this style is the next and we'll check
if there is a brighter tile
neighbor tile and we'll find these two
and both has the same color
so it will just pick one of them and you
can see it
decreases the light a little bit so it
can fall off
the light value otherwise it will just
flood the level with the same
light then we'll continue like this
and then the light would spread like
this all over the level a good thing
with this
is that we can actually get the light a
little bit into the corridor like this
so when you enter the room here you
already see the light here
when the walls calculate the light they
always set the light value to zero
because we don't want light to spread
through walls
so it's always zero
okay so now when i have this light map
what do i do with it well for the floors
it's quite easily i just set the light
value of the tile
but for the walls well each wall is
built of four corners
and each corner will check
like this into the light it's facing and
it will do like that
this wall and this wall will have the
same color as this tile
this wall is having the color of this
style
and finally this wall the other side of
the wall
it's it's the same tile but it's
the other side of the wall well without
this will be zero
so the light would never never spread
through it's a very silly algorithm but
it's very fast in javascript
and the whole level just takes a few
milliseconds to process
[Music]
and that was my game searching for a
four that i made for years 13k
2020. you can find me at my not very
updated blog
at snooki.se or at nikasloof at twitter
or my youtube channel
[Music]
you can also find me at spotify and
other streaming services
since i'm also making music and the tune
you ever heard in this
video is mine you can search for album
recollecting memories by niklas love
thanks for watching and year 2021 i
challenge you to also participate in
jay's 13k
try it it's a lot of fun and if i could
do it i bet you can easily do it too
this recording is being done on behalf
of paul brunt
paul brunt says i'm just your standard
web guy building websites for a living
and i love graphic programming and
making games in my spare time
this year's game for gs 13k was my
fourth entry for the competition
it's basically a platform game with a
twist instead of jumping as you would in
a traditional platform game
you control a light source that costs
shadows that you can walk on
i came up with the idea early on when i
was just doing some array casting to add
some lighting effects
at the time the shadows were casting in
the same color as the platform and there
was no visual distinction
so i thought why not make them act as a
platform
as well my favorite piece of code in the
game was the collision detection code
it still blows my mind that with nothing
more than some pythagoras
you can perform what seems to be really
complicated collisions
the code isn't that complex but i
believe it's the first time i've taken
the maths from scribbles
and implemented it in code without
making any silly mistakes
it all worked as intended from the
get-go so a very rare event
the shadows are made up of a bunch of
line segments and the code checks the
distance of the player's bounding circle
from the line segments if the line is
less than the radius of the bounding
circle away
then a collision occurs and the normal
and overlap distance is returned
the nice part of writing this code was
that i don't venture into the world of
2d much
but the 3d stuff i've learned over
recent years transferred over really
well
as a result there wasn't as much head
scratching as i'd first anticipated when
i originally came up with the idea of
making the shadows
part of the environment thanks so much
for watching my video and as always you
will find my website and my twitter
handle as well as my game
in the description below please do check
it out
this video is going to be read by any
okubo based on a post morten on github
for this game
by ben clark and salvatore privity
island not found is a game that is
rendered primarily using a technique
called ray marching or sphere tracing
this is where you define the world as a
mathematical function representing a
distance to the nearest geometry
it is much more inefficient in
processing than standard polygonal
rasterization
but appears to be much more effective in
code size
curved surfaces are easier to render
with better fidelity
and less overhead since there is no
triangulation involved
ben and salvatore met up one day after
work after the theme
404 was announced and began deciding
what they should build
the general linking of these things from
404 was ideas about finding things being
lost you know lost the television series
not knowing where you are
a code piece that they used in their
post-mortem was this
it is all about code golfing salvatore
says
while for our previous game last year we
didn't have to put much energy in code
golfing
this time much more effort was required
a large portion of the final bundle is
occupied by glsl
code to reuse functions uniforms and
variables across multiple shaders the
best solution was to have a single big
file and switch the main function to use
a string replace when loading
the glsl transpiler on the browser
already performed unused functions
elimination
and constant folding so it was not
concerned to load unused variables and
functions
you can read more about this piece of
code on the postmortem online that is
attached to the github game
please do enjoy the read and do give ben
and salvatore
a follow on twitter as well
oh and if you're curious about what this
game looks like in a single picture of
code
this is it pretty cool
for this video i'm going to be using a
postmortem that
mark posted on github
speaking as mark a little bit about you
have found
it's a soothing game about perspective
it's important to turn your sound on
head votes advice tap and hold to move
the trail make a loop to catch things if
you want
getting started to prove to myself that
it is perfectly possible to use hakes
for this
i started to create a small engine in
hakes
i called the project hx13k initially
higgs is a programming language that
compiles to many languages
including javascript es6 as
mainly part of my daily job i am a game
developer
and make html5 advert games so i like
the idea of this gem
first i started by making a basic engine
well actually i stripped down the setup
i normally use
which is a combination of pixy js and a
customized flambe
library i'm a big fan of using entity
components and the way that flambe
library did it is how i like to work
it's very pragmatic
and usable for creating games in the end
pixie js was removed as a render because
it was too big
it's too bad because pixie gs is such a
great fast 2d rendering framework
if you would like to read more about my
game please do visit on github and have
a go yourself
hi my name is jeremy and i'm a game
developer from edmonton canada
and i made 404 kph for the 2020 js 13k
games jam i first got the idea to make a
driving game of some kind after last
year's jam
last year some friends and i made a game
where you would fly through canyons
and i thought it would be neat to drive
a monster truck over the sort of canyony
bumpy terrain
however once this year's jam started and
i started prototyping
i i just couldn't quite get the monster
truck physics to feel good
but uh the physics ended up being pretty
good for a car
so i looked to one of my favorite uh
racing games which is trackmania
and decided to get some inspiration from
that and kind of go into the
surreal crazy physics-y uh time trials
type racing
direction the game itself has a pretty
strange architecture in order to stay
under 13 kilobytes
for instance the audio is done through a
custom synth that's essentially hard
coded to produce the game's music and
other sound effects
also the game's state is stored in a
small texture and all the game update
code including the physics and
everything
is run inside of a fragment shader on
the gpu
and this is done in order to share some
code and data between
the rendering and physics code as well
as to make use of the really terse
vector math functions
that are available in the shader coding
languages
on top of that the build system runs a
series of like custom steps in order to
make the final html file
more friendly to zipping and just
squeeze a couple of extra bytes out of
that
the thing i'm most excited about though
is probably the level editor
i mentioned that the game update code
runs inside of a shader this is done
partially because the world is
represented as a signed distance field
or sdf
you can think of an sdf as a function
that takes a point in space and returns
the
distance to the nearest surface in that
space sdfs are really easy to render and
they're really easy to test collision
against which is why i chose them as a
representation for the tracks
however this means i have to represent
the tracks as a collection of functions
in order to not go crazy trying to
manually write functions for every
individual track
i decided to build a unity plugin where
i could
represent different components of a
track
as their own functions but then
translate scale and change the
properties of them
just by dragging around the objects in
the editor
the editor then when i hit
build will generate a bunch of shader
code
which is the sign distance function
itself
so i get the benefits of sort of a gui
editor
and i can see my work as i'm working on
it i get a really quick iteration time
um but it's still generating this sign
distance function in the end which i can
just embed directly into the game
and so that's how the editor it works
for 404 kph
and that's how i built all of the tracks
i actually built all of the tracks that
are in the final game on the last day of
the jam
because i was busy building everything
else up until then
this is a recording based on elliot's
github repo
wizard with a shotgun is a top down 2d
shooter
you have the wizard recover the missing
pages of the shotgun arcana from the
dungeon by blasting everything you see
play on your desktop using any browser
and use the controls of your keyboard
and your mouse
the main character is intended to be a
sort of wise cracking
street smart wizard think harry dresser
not harry potter
the main character also has this awesome
text show up
unfortunately elliot discovered that
dialogue is very expensive in the final
zip file
so i had to cut a lot of the planned
lines there's a few things that elliot
says he's really proud of in this game
and these are some of them
elliott says the first is my approach to
canvas size
this game is intended to look like a
classic 2d pixel art game
so i selected 480 480x270 as my desired
display pixels then what i do is make
the canvas element take up the full size
of the browser
and i select the smallest scale that
would fill the canvas horizontally and
vertically
now i end up with a 2d context that was
always roughly
480 by 270 but it might be less wide or
tall depending on the browse dimension
if you want to see what i'm describing
try playing my game and dragging your
browser window around to resize it
you'll see that the ratio stays fixed
and the scale will adjust it
to give you as much playing real estate
as possible while still looking nice
i'm pretty happy with this and will
likely keep the algorithm for my future
games
the second is the collision response
this year i chose to simplify and use
bounding circles instead of rectangles
which meant i needed some
math for the circle rectangle walls and
circle circle
player enemy collision detection i'm
pretty proud of the result which is
quite a bit of code
but allows you to totally surrounded by
multiple adjusting enemies
and still push your way out of them all
while looking about like you want it to
look
the same math applies to any moving
object with a position and velocity
which meant i accomplished what i could
not last year
another thing i tried and i'm happy with
is breaking up logic into systems
it's not for nc component system or
anything but my upgrade loop now works
in specific stages
first behavior where the entity thinks
then movement where velocity is applied
and collision
detection happens then damage damage
queued up by the first two rounds
is now applied to each entity
potentially killing it
last culled entities are cleaned up
this made it easier to figure out where
to put logic and helps keep the main
game update function nice and clean
i didn't want to mess around with the
level editor so i used ask sprite to
draw the map
and then my gut build turns it into
level data
each room is color coded to represent a
particular pattern number
which controls the type and quantities
of enemies in the room
this wouldn't cut it if i had multiple
tiles and entities and decorative
objects to place
but for this game it worked pretty well
if you want to see more about this game
please do check out the github below
connection is a game made by federico
tibaldo
it is a pattern-based puzzle game
connect the tiles on the board with your
fingers and mouse to replicate the given
combination or press the not bound
button
play through the levels to unlock the
arcade mode and ultimately
achieve the final trophy some feedback
from the expert says
dan sullivan really really enjoyed this
first mode was a bit
tough as was the 30 plus in arcade but
otherwise a really really fantastic
little puzzle
reflex game i will not be going through
the
code for this game however if you want
to have a look at how federico made this
game
in less than 13kb please do check out
his github
in the description below
this video is read on behalf of marcus
i am a software developer from nuremberg
germany primarily i write apps for
android and sometimes for other systems
too
a bit about the game and how you go
through it
my game is a short adventure game about
two cosmonauts getting lost in space
the player needs to find the way home by
solving a couple of puzzles
i chose cosmonauts because the story is
about a secret escape drive and such
things are more likely to be attributed
to the mysterious early russian space
program
originally i had a much darker story in
mind
two cosmonauts on the way to venus one
dies for unknown reasons
the survivor fastens the dead man
outside the capsule and is from then on
haunted by mysterious happenings
outside the window so essentially a
ghost story in space
but somehow the story did not really
work and i focus on getting lost in the
space thing instead
which is really enough for an adventure
in 13kb
but the idea with the dream sequence
still comes from the original story
when asked what marcus was most proud of
he says i'm afraid there isn't a snippet
i am particularly proud of
instead the challenge to make this game
was to squeeze the graphics into 13kb
and still have enough left for an
adventure game
so minimizing the size of the vector
graphics was key
to improve compression i only used
integer coordinates on a 100 by 100
canvas to make
doubles by doubles i mean doubles of
coordinate numbers
this way there were just a hundred
possible coordinate numbers
from 0 to 99 for all the vertices of all
the graphics
this code here this is the hull of the
soyuz spaceship defined in just a few
integer numbers that occurs later on and
a lot of other shapes
and since repetitive string patterns can
be compressed very well
i was able to pack all graphics and the
game in 13kb
this way thanks for watching my video
and you can find me on twitter
github or on my website these are all in
the description below
hi i'm sarah zamek i'm a web developer
with a passion for graphics the web
music and design for this year's js 13k
competition
i created a puzzle game heavily inspired
by the puzzle system
and paper mario the origami king the
goal in my game
is to create a symmetrical sequence of
symbols by sliding and rotating them
on top of that for each puzzle there's a
time limit and a life system
as you've seen the game takes place on
what i'd like to call a roller coaster
i'm going to talk about how i
implemented it and how i got there
pretty early on i decided that the
puzzles should be solved while racing on
an infinite track that goes left and
right randomly
but also very smoothly while working out
how to approach this i quickly realized
i may have been a bit too ambitious
creating an infinite random track that
feels also smooth
isn't easy but then i had my first
eureka moment
needs to feel like it's infinite it
doesn't have to be infinite
i can just define a path that's super
big and eventually loops back on itself
what better way than to just define the
parametric curve using sines and cosines
i experimented a bit with sine and
cosines and settled on this definition
of the parametric curve
however the rollercoaster is not just a
curve every point also needs an
orientation
i need to know what's forward and what's
up for every point
forward this simple it's just the
derivative of the parametric curve
but what way is up well the curve loops
around the origin
so i guess i can just use this as the up
vector alright
well it works but as you can see it
doesn't really feel
quite right at least to me it doesn't
but then after some dueling i have my
second eureka moment
second derivative now what if i use the
second derivative as an up vector
as you can see it's perfect
and that's how i created the basis of a
streamingly influenced smooth roller
coaster
hope you learned something
we have now come to our last and final
winner of the js 13k
games 2020. feedback from the experts
is this jupiter hardly says really
impressive sound machine
bjorn rizzo absolute genius i really
look forward to seeing what people will
be able to create with this
is there already some place where people
can share their creations
and michelle mannering goes oh my god
it's like scrabble
great instructions good documentation
and nice work
thanking everyone this maybe is not so
much a game as a platform to create
musical creations using coach it also
has some awesome demos of what you can
make
like for example the intro to mario
i'm not going to go through the code for
this one so simply enjoy
okay so there we have it those were this
year's winners for the js 13k
games 2020. i really do hope this video
has inspired you to go
forth and create some games i mean it
definitely inspired me
i loved being a judge on it and i can't
wait
to see your submissions it doesn't
matter if you're just running out
doesn't matter if you've been doing this
for years and the creativity that comes
out of it is just so inspiring it's
amazing
i mean it's just mind-blowing so don't
forget all the developers
are in the description below if you want
to check them out as well as their games
and the source code to their games
i'm also going to put a link to andrea's
competition in the description and of
course please do like and subscribe
to this video and my own channel my
youtube channel
if you enjoyed this and would like to
see more thanks very much
and i'll see you soon